c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur france 24 à la
une ce soir klahn corp l'un des géants
mondiaux dans le négoce des produits
pétroliers qui plaide coupable devant
les tribunaux américains et britanniques
pour des faits de corruption le cameroun
est cité dans cette affaire tentaculaire
des hauts fonctionnaires auraient perçu
l 7 milliards de francs cfa l'opposition
demandent des comptes nous serons à
yaoundé dans ce journal
élections législatives au sénégal le
ministre de l'intérieur a le ministère
de l'intérieur a validé huit listes
nationales de candidats alors que deux
listes dont celle de la principale
coalition d'opposition ont été jugées
irrecevables les réactions à dakar dans
ce journal
la fête au maroc hier son club mythique
du wydad casablanca a remporté la ligue
des champions africaine de but à 0
contre le club cairote d'al ahly les
réactions à casablanca et au caire dans
ce journal
7 milliards de francs cfa soit 10
millions d'euros de pots-de-vin versés à
des ondes fonctionnaires camerounais
c'est ce qu'a révélé le groupe glenn
clore à la justice britannique et
américaine l'un des géants mondiaux font
du négoce des produits pétroliers a
plaidé coupable pour des faits de
corruption
l'opposition camerounaise camerounaise
demande des comptes aux autorités les
précisions de notre correspondant à
yaoundé marcel amont qu'aux seuls
falashas times qui a été le premier a
levé le lièvre dans un article daté du
24 mai dernier le journal anglais
révélait que le négociant anglo suisse
glencore était prêt à plaider coupable
des faits de corruption pour obtenir ou
conserver les contrats dans des entités
publiques dirigé par l'état dans
plusieurs pays africains notamment la
côte d'ivoire à la guinée équatoriale au
nigeria ou encore le cameroun glencore
qui comparaissaient devant des tribunaux
américains et anglais pour ce qui est du
cameroun grandeurs affirme avoir versé
plus de 7 milliards de francs cfa un peu
plus de 10 millions d'euros de
pots-de-vin des dirigeants de l'asm âge
la société nationale des hydrocarbures
et de la sonara la société nationale de
raffinage un scandale de corruption qui
a poussé l'avocat acquérez à mon ancien
président de transparence international
ici au cameroun la saisir la connaître
la commission nationale anti corruption
l'ancien bâtonnier de l'ordre des
avocats du cameroun n'est d'ailleurs pas
le seul à exiger que toute la lumière
soit faite sur ce scandale de corruption
puisque certains leaders de l'opposition
ont également demandé à la justice
camerounaise de se saisir de ce dossier
le député sdf joshua osih demande même
la création d'une commission d' enquête
parlementaire autant dire que ce
scandale de corruption qui n'est pas
très surprenant dans un pays plusieurs
fois classé numéro 1 mondial en matière
de corruption l'année qu'à ses prémices
le gouvernement camerounais n'a pour
l'instant pas réagi silence radio
également du côté de la sonara et de la
snh
et puis toujours au cameroun dans la
zone anglophone en proie à un sanglant
conflit 24 civils ont été tués et une
soixantaine ont été blessés dimanche par
des séparatistes armés dans le sud-ouest
du pays quelques heures auparavant
l'armée avait annoncé avoir libéré
plusieurs otages dont elisabeth regina
mundi une sénatrice du parti
présidentiel enlevé il y à un mois par
des indépendantistes anglophone l'armée
camerounaise affirme avoir tué une
dizaine de ravisseurs dans l'opération
de sauvetage
au sénégal la principale coalition
d'opposition y est mis à ce cas nouy
pourrait ne pas présenter de candidats
aux élections législatives de juillet à
cette liste ainsi que celle des
suppléants de la coalition de la
majorité
benno boc yaakaar ont été déclarées
irrecevables par le ministère de
l'intérieur au total huit listes ont été
validées pour ce scrutin les réactions à
dakar avec notre correspondante sara
sakho selon l'arrêté du ministère de
l'intérieur de listes nationales sont
rejetés la liste de suppléant de la
coalition au pouvoir bénévoles qui a car
pour cause de non respect de la parité
la liste de titulaire cette fois de la
coalition d'opposition y ait eu un scan
louis liste jugé non complète la
formation avait par erreur investi deux
fois la même personne concrètement cela
veut dire pour la formation d'opposition
que des personnalités comme ousman sonko
tête de liste ou encore malick gackou
autre figure de l'opposition ici au
sénégal ne pourront participer seront
remplacés par leurs suppléants les
réactions n'ont pas tardé la coalition
d'opposition dénoncent une provocation
du pouvoir et promet que ses partisans
descendront cette fin de semaine dans
les rues de dakar pour manifester pour
protester quand à la coalition benno boc
ya car elle invoque l une erreur
matérielle que la commission de
réception des listes ne lui aurait pas
signifié et dans les deux cas les
formations annonce des recours auprès de
la cour constitutionnelle
l'institution a trois jours pour statuer
sur leur sort
on va s'intéresser à présent à
l'opposant égyptien alaa abdelfattah son
état de santé préoccupant cela fait
soixante jours qu'il a entamé une grève
de la faim en prison depuis huit ans
icône de la révolution il a été
transféré vers une prison dite modèle
après les mauvais traitements qu'il a
subis dans le centre pénitentiaire de
tora
mais ses soutiens continus a demandé sa
libération reportage de notre
correspondant au caire qui doit dropsy
à la dalle fatah est en prison depuis
2014 pour ses opinions politiques
en dehors d'une courte libération en
2019 sa mère ne le voit que derrière les
barreaux elle garde ses lettres
précieusement
en dehors des visites c'est la chose la
plus importante pour moi
durant des années il a dû dormir par
terre n'a pas pu faire d'exercice ni
écrire si ses conditions de détention se
sont améliorées récemment il est
affaibli par sa grève de la faim
même si je voulais en discuter avec lui
comment peut-on vivre dans ces
conditions
bien sûr que je le soutiens je dois le
soutenir
je sais que s'il est libéré
il pourra reprendre sa vie en main
mais d'anouar el sadate le neveu de
l'ancien raïs est en charge de la
médiation entre les prisonniers
politiques et les autorités égyptiennes
un dialogue national a été lancé il ya
quelques mois et il veut croire en un
assouplissement du régime
je crois que lorsque le président a
appelé pour ce dialogue national
et qu'il a lancé cette stratégie pour
les droits de l'homme c'est une sorte de
reconnaissance par le régime qu'il est
temps d'apaiser la situation
is
dans un pays où l'on compte au moins
soixante mille prisonniers politiques la
situation est loin d'être résolue pour
ce défenseur des droits de l'homme l'un
des derniers en egypte le régime doit
donner un signal fort s'il veut être à
la hauteur de ses ambitions
donnerait ce signal à tout le monde
que le grand tramway de pages sans
réparation dans l'air les gens vont pas
le croire halladay le fatah désormais le
soutien du royaume uni dont il vient
d'acquérir la nationalité mais ses
chances de libération restent faibles
la réaction au rwanda du ministre des
affaires étrangères vincent biruta art
il a rejeté une nouvelle fois lors d'une
conférence de presse les accusations de
son voisin congolais kinshasa affirme
pour rappel que le rwanda soutient le
groupe rebelle m23 qui sévit dans l'est
du pays et kigali de son côté accusent
l'armée congolaise de s'être allié avec
le groupe rebelle hutu fdlr
je vous propose d'écouter le ministre
rwandais des affaires étrangères
il y a eu de nombreuses réunions avec le
gouvernement de la république
démocratique du congo pour élaborer un
plan de lutte contre ces groupes armés
mais nous n'avons pas été en mesure de
le mettre en oeuvre
et nous considérons que c'est le
résultat d'un manque de volonté
politique du côté de la rdc mais ce
n'est pas une affaire personnelle entre
le président kagame le président
tshisekedi
deuxième semaine de grève au ministère
des finances congolais à brazzaville un
mouvement qui se durcit 1500
travailleurs de la direction générale du
budget ont décidé de poursuivre leur
grève tant que les autorités ne
répondent pas favorablement à leurs
revendications la correspondance à
brazzaville de rosie piotte
couloirs vides bureaux déserts fait la
fait plus d'une semaine que les
activités sont perturbés au sein de la
direction générale de budget les agents
grévistes réclament entre autres les
paiement de leurs primes des commissions
des sommes dues pour le travail effectué
hors jours et heures réglementaires
ces rêveurs indications date de
plusieurs années sans résultat les cas
des retraités toujours en activité
préoccupe particulièrement les syndicats
le second consultation s'agissait du du
respect des départs à la retraite bon
c'est juste nous avons remarqué que
comme enfin et qui les agents qui
faisait valoir leur doit la retraite
continuer à exercer et là vous savez le
syndicat son rôle c'est de veiller au
bien-être social et à la carrière des
agents donc ce point-là fait partie
des problèmes là que les agents
réclament les syndicalistes qui
affirment avoir repris les négociations
avec les autorités insistent sur le fait
que les départs à la retraite et non
négociable au vu des textes en vigueur
qui régissent le statut du travailleur
contacté le ministre délégué au budget
n'a pas donné suite à nos sollicitations
et en tunisie lui gtt l'union générale
tunisienne du travail puissant syndicat
fort de plus d'un million d'adhérents a
lancé mardi un appel à une grève
nationale pour le 16 juin un appel à
cesser le travail dans les services et
le secteur public face au refus du
gouvernement d'augmenter les salaires
malgré l'inflation
en tanzanie pour lutter contre la cherté
de la vie aggravée par l'inflation le
gouvernement s'est engagé à
subventionner le carburant à partir du
1er juin la mesure va coûter plus de 40
millions d'euros les précisions de
camille nédélec
en réponse à la flambée des prix en
tanzanie le gouvernement met en oeuvre
plusieurs mesures d'urgence y compris la
subvention du carburant les dirigeants
espèrent aussi augmenter leurs recettes
nationales avec le développement du
secteur des hydrocarbures
nous mettrons en place des subventions
pétrolière dans un avenir proche et nous
commencerons également à construire des
installations d'exportation de pétrole
parmi les projets qui pourraient
bénéficier de ce nouvel élan une usine
de gaz naturel liquéfié dans la ville de
lindy au sud est de la tanzanie sont ces
créer des milliers d'emplois le
gouvernement a demandé des prêts au fmi
et la banque mondiale pour subventionner
les prix des produits du quotidien une
urgence selon cet économiste
le problème ce sont les impôts la
tanzanie demande au demande de réduire
les impôts dès que possible autant qu'il
le peut afin de faire face à la
situation les citoyens tanzaniens sont
en difficulté nous sommes en crise nous
sommes confrontés à une véritable crise
économique
avant même la flambée du prix du pétrole
liée à la guerre en ukraine la situation
était critique un transilien sur dix vit
en dessous du seuil de pauvreté et un
tiers des enfants souffrent de
malnutrition chronique
ce sont les marocains du wydad
casablanca qui ont remporté la finale de
la ligue des champions d'afrique 2 but à
0 aux dépens des la relie le club du
caire en egypte un match dominé par les
casablancais qui jouaient à domicile ont
fait le point avec jules boiteau avec
aussi les images de nos correspondants
au maroc et en egypte jean marie lemaire
et ahmed el safti
dans les rues de casablanca
des centaines de supporters en liesse
petits et grands sont venus célébrer la
victoire du mit d'adp en finale de la
ligue des champions d'afrique
c'est la troisième fois que le club
remporte la compétition
[Applaudissements]
titre parce qu'elle est elle est elle
meilleure équipe et avec beaucoup de
courage avec des jeunes joueurs on est
champions d'afrique
marotte édition vient des champions ont
porté par zouhair el moutard hadji
l'attaquant du wydad héros de la finale
il a inscrit les deux seuls buts d'une
frappe superbe à la 15e minute puis d'un
tir à bout portant juste après le retour
des vestiaires
vainqueur d'al ahly le club le plus
titré d'afrique avec 10 ligue des
champions les rouges de casa ont pu
soulever la coupe devant leurs
supporters qui avaient massivement
investi le stade mohammed-v de
casablanca un choix d'enceinte contestée
par les égyptiens mais leur recours
devant le tribunal arbitral du sport
pour jouer sur un autre terrain a été
rejetée on voulait jouer sur un terrain
neutre ce n'est pas juste le match s'est
joué devant mille supporters égyptiens
contre 50 mille supporters marocains au
moins
notre niveau de jeu était assez faible
les joueurs n'ont pas arrêter de
balancer les ballons devant je ne sais
pas si c'était à cause de la pression
des supporters marocains mais on a très
mal joué
avec trois ligues des champions
d'afrique le wydad rejoint au palmarès
l'autre grand club de casablanca et son
grand rival le raja club athletic
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique rester avec nous dans quelques
instants la suite de paris direct avec
audrey racines
[Musique]